aeropuerto de bari este de francia esa
mañana fuimos testigos de una escena
inusual para un aeródromo cielo francia
desea demostrar que está preparada y
equipada para hacer frente al regreso de
una guerra convencional entre países
estos hombres forman parte del segundo
regimiento extranjero de paracaidistas
embarcamos para un ejercicio de salto el
primero de una sesión de entrenamiento
este ejercicio de cuatro días comienza
con un lanzamiento de paracaidistas de
portería lo que le permite proyectar una
fuerza significativa a lo largo y ancho
para combinar tanto la sorpresa como el
volumen de fuerza significativo
el objetivo del personal era enseñar a
los soldados a defenderse contra un
estado con medios similares a los de
francia
[Música]
la alta intensidad es el modo de
enfrentamiento para el que los ejércitos
franceses se preparan desde hace varios
meses y que les permitirá poner a prueba
tanto los dirigentes como a los soldados
en su capacidad de enfrentarse a lo que
llamamos un enemigo en igualdad de
condiciones al amanecer nos encontramos
de nuevo con los legionarios después de
su salto aprovecharon la cobertura de la
noche para avanzar hasta este pequeño
pueblo falso los locales están ocupados
por una fuerza enemiga ficticia ahora
deben desalojar la y recuperar el
control
un escenario meticulosamente preparado
esta formación también reforzará la
cooperación inter ejércitos entre los
distintos cuerpos del ejército
por ejemplo tomaremos un artillero un
soldado de infantería un jinete un
sacador y lo agruparemos se pondrán bajo
la autoridad del mismo líder y se les
dará una misión y va a resolver
problemas tácticos mucho más complejos
posiciones movimientos disparos minas
activadas las acciones de los soldados
son supervisadas y evaluadas en tiempo
real desde este centro operativo de alta
tecnología
este lugar es único es un poco la meca
del combate de alta intensidad tenemos
un sistema único que solo se ha
desplegado en el centac y en el
campamento de miley camp si francia
refuerza la formación de sus militares
es porque el mundo está en pleno proceso
de rearme en 2020 el gasto militar
mundial ascendió a 2 billones de dólares
según el instituto internacional de
investigación para la paz una cifra que
es un 2,6 por ciento superior a la de
2019 a pesar de la pandemia
desde hace algunos años las fuerzas
armadas pero también las fuerzas
especializadas observan un regreso a la
competencia estratégica entre las
grandes potencias con la reaparición de
rusia y la marcada aparición de china y
cierto número de otras potencias
militares que se imponen mediante la
adquisición de equipos modernos de alto
rendimiento les confieren capacidades
militares que ellos no tenían hasta
entonces francia responde a la amenaza
con una ley de programación militar la
nueva ley de programación militar de
manuel macro no eleva el presupuesto de
defensa al 2%
para 2025 la ley de programación militar
es un verdadero esfuerzo de la nación y
somos muy conscientes de ello en nuestra
opinión esto era completamente esencial
vamos a renovar los equipos que tienen
más de 30 años yo era un teniente común
jim un rifle un misil antitanque soy un
general y sigue igual esta financiación
acelera la renovación del envejecido
equipamiento de las fuerzas armadas los
vehículos blindados delanteros
introducidos hace 45 años están siendo
sustituidos por nuevos vehículos
blindados los gryphons mientras que los
fusiles de asalto franceses fueron
sustituidos por un momento alemán más
barato en munición una apertura europea
quizás una premonición de una mayor
cooperación en la defensa del continente